you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy network atc
this is a bicycle american history
podcast for each week i
dave anthony sit on a bicycle and read a
story from american history to my friend
gareth reynolds who's also on a bicycle
and has no idea what the topic is going
to be about
ding ding
we have fun we
enjoy the intros and well we mix it up
don't we we do and we do and it's we
don't plan these no this was total off
the cuff yep foolery just seated the
pants but you know what's also fun is i
never know if you're going to do your
jobs or not and you haven't lately no i
i barely i barely have ever i'm not good
at this no no i mean where you say
holder of candles yeah yeah maker of you
know
terrible decisions
gross
pile
dave anthony no i've never said that's
not i'm not i'm not quoting you but i'm
saying it's in the realm of it's not in
the realm it's close it's section down
in the realm you definitely called
yourself a gross pile i've never said
grow i've never said i'm a gross pile
you have off air at minimum no i've
never seen you said to me before
uh i mean i'm sorry i'm a gross pile i
i've never actually breakfast like three
you're thinking of someone else i'm not
there's nobody else i would no come on
pam no it's not oh that's it aaron go to
commercial
oh then we gotta wait for that oh this
is so awkward but that was a great
and called it quote his jam patch
and this is not gonna become the
tickling podcast okay this is like adam
and a five-part confession
now hit him with a puppy
you both present sick arguments no sleep
deal hippo
action partner
hi gabby no i see dad my friend
um
should we start with the bad news uh
well i know in this world that people
like they want to you know there's not a
lot of bad news nowadays so for a change
up maybe let's hit him with it
uh the australia tour is
off
postponed postponed
we're very bummed and uh we just found
out uh and actually i even announced i
was saying this to dave i announced a
date on the show
and it was during our quarantine and we
hadn't even gotten the word yet so i was
about to maybe try to change that date
and um and then yeah we got the word
last night because things are going so
poorly there that uh yeah it's just not
realistic and feasible with all the
quarantines we'd have to do and just in
general it's like i think we would have
we would have more trouble getting in
there now than than we would before yeah
they're not gonna let they're not gonna
let anybody in and also the
the theaters this they're gonna space
and it's not it's not gonna yeah be
feasible and then
how many states could we get into yeah
we would so sorry uh i i feel bad mostly
for new zealand
yeah they're taking the hit no they
could have had the best they could have
the best time yeah new zealand like
no it's like it's like you're a side car
on a motorbike that's going off the road
like what are you going to do you're
just you're sitting you're like oh god
damn it i'm attached to this thing
um but yeah so but we are deaf we
already talking about when we can try to
do it again and so uh if there if you
weren't already motivated to uh
be safe and uh wear your mask and
socially distance and not be a prick uh
do it now and get vaccinated if you can
because yeah you know if you can they're
getting vaccinated down there they're
bringing it along so hopefully by
october november they'll be vaccinated
yeah they're going to have their share
of idiots like we do oh yeah but just
not as many americans well they're going
to be too shorter
because of us um but uh but yeah so
we're bummed but we do still have a good
amount of uh dates here in the states
that we are excited about and uh we
certainly don't want uh this bad news to
hinder any of that so uh just to go
through those very quickly we will be at
wise guys in las vegas on september 14th
the 16th will be a wise guy salt lake
city then we'll be at the high plains
comedy festival saturday september 18th
at the paramount theater we will be at
stand up live in phoenix arizona uh
november 5th the palace of the fine arts
san francisco and then we will be at the
crest theater saturday november 6th in
sacramento and san diego we will be
there december 10th at the observatory
north park which uh is your favorite
venue i believe i
personally will be uh braving it in
texas where covetous will be happening
for me uh i'll be at hyenas in dallas on
the 19th of august the 20th of august
i'll be at the
uh i'll be at the state theater in
austin texas uh then i'll be at the rec
room in houston then i'll be at the
spokane comedy club in uh august 26th
i'll be at the tacoma comedy club august
27th and 28th i'll be at the stress
factory in new jersey september 10th
and then that goes into our australia
dates which we've already talked about
so you're doing a you're doing a the
delta run you're doing it serious delta
run you're going to
spokane and texas yeah you're in it yup
going right into the fire i'm going up
to the devil's ass not allowed to not
allowed to mask in texas
yeah
well but i'll say in my experience of
where i'm going in clubs it's it'll be
probably not very different i mean they
really are not like you know i will say
though
more and more people at shows are
wearing masks so oh good yeah um you
know
it's the little wins um but yeah so go
to garrett thrones.com for uh those
details
we are brought to you in part by a
ritual look rituals uh it's a
multivitamin took it today
yesterday
i'll take tomorrow me as well rituals
clean vegan-friendly multivitamin is
formulated with high nutrients in
bioavailable forms your body can
actually use yup can actually use them
you're not going to find sugars gmos
major allergens synthetic fillers
artificial colorants not there uh gareth
and i we both take ritual i've i'm i've
i'm a vitamin guy i take vitamins i'm
not multivitamin i boy has been but this
one
first of all the taste and the and the
non-nausea thing which that's got a mint
kick in your throat as it goes down yeah
and i actually didn't take a
multivitamin because of the reasons that
they invented ritual because i was like
what's your hair yeah it seemed a little
dicey yeah because there's no law that
says that anybody has to tell you it's
in a vitamin so rituals doing it right
very nice yes
uh ritual is made traceable like we're
saying you always know what nutrients
you
you're taking and where they come from
thanks to rituals one of a kind visible
chain
and it's designed with your life stage
in mind so it's for women men teens
ritual vitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages
get key nutrients without the bs rituals
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
dollop to start your ritual today
we're also brought to you in part by
squarespace
squarespace it's a domain website online
store marketing tool analytics thing
it's a sure it's just a monster of uh
they do it all makes you feel smart
about making a website that's right
and i've been uh using squarespace
forever
since they've since they started really
because i first started using it because
it it looked great the clean templates
super easy to use which is for me i'm a
big dummy when it comes to stuff like
this drives me crazy in a lot of ways a
lot of ways i'm really stupid
and uh this is dumb dummy proof
uh it's so i it it looks really great
and then an idiot like me because i
can't do anything technical i spend
hours
i'm also an idiot yeah
uh and then you know you got all kinds
of stuff you got marketing tools you
want to email marketing you want to do
social media integration banners
promotions analytics they got
everything everything you would want
gareth yep that's why i use it for not
only my website but we also use it for
the dollop and you use it for your
website yeah we do it so we do it for
the sources page and that's right we are
all in on squarespace 100
so look uh
check out squarespace.com for free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code dollop to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or
domain yeah
and we are brought to you in part
by
squarespace wait squarespace
sorry we are brought to you in part by
stamps.com that's better the other
s ask thing yes
uh stamps.com i've been using for a long
time
uh look things are getting back to
normal right things are chugging along
more of a normal life ahead
so finally you can get back to enjoying
life's little pleasures
like saying hi to your neighbor taking
your dog to the park
going to movies going to the post office
no let's not do that we can still stay
at home we don't have to go to the post
office
we can do everything we want right from
our own computer yes because of
stamps.com
stamps.com brings the
same us postal and ups shipping services
right to your computer they uh make it
super easy for small businesses to mail
and ship like you yeah yeah you've sent
me a couple places in those it's called
the garfield where you sent me to abu
dhabi that's correct without needing to
take a trip to the post office the uh
print official us postage and shipping
labels 24 7 without having to leave your
desk
or you don't have to buy anything fancy
you can just do it right there yep just
a computer or printer bam that's it it's
very easy and then once it's ready you
just uh schedule right there on the
computer for a gentleman or a gentlelady
or
you know binary whoever is coming to
come and uh
pick it up or drop it off whatever you
want sure that's it that's that easy
uh so
like i said i've been using it i find it
really really really convenient i also
use it very easy yeah it's super very
helpful it's so so helpful you can also
get like 40 off use
ups this up to 66 off ups
shipping rates so stop wasting time
going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk and
with our promo code you get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
dollop that's stamps.com promo code
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
[Music]
is that do i have anything else i don't
know do you
aaron do we have anything else to
announce
okay what about the guns
yeah that's
yeah that's where i keep the white yeah
i was just gonna say i mean it does it
looks you almost looks like you don't
have a bicep it's faded completely there
we go that's better
yeah yeah it is it is you have a real
freckle line
yeah i really do yeah
it's hot
some ladies like it yeah this one does
yeah
year of
our lord
jesus christ
william contrell was born and sorry
william cottrell was born in cedar
key florida okay
so cedar key is a city in levy county
uh florida which is off the gulf coast
so it's on the right on the gulf side
sure uh so cedar key they see it's a
group of islands
okay north of tampa bay it's like an
arca archipelago sort of situation
in 1842
the u.s passed the armed occupation act
to increase white settlement in florida
the best kind of settlement
you know you want to go what are really
white so what are they really saying
what they're basically like let's get
rid of everybody who's not allowed to
yeah it's basically like how can we get
more white people down here to really
get this it's just unfair when you're
creating the thing you're like we have
these things called laws it's like oh
well we're not like actually practicing
those it's like well tough [ __ ] ours are
pretty bad for you
yeah it's pretty great yeah um so this
is one of the ways that congress is
trying to get
the seminals out of the area right the
people
the the people who lived there forever
well we tried talking to them
and then we tried killing them but let's
double kill him let's stop but we're not
going to go back to the talking board
uh
so an army base was uh built at cedar
keys and then it was abandoned
and so that was now available for
sediment so settlement so people started
coming in and moving there okay
and then the city became a really
important port
it became import important port like a
very important port important important
thank you
uh like the most important part on that
in that area okay and um there's a lot
of cedar trees that's why it's called
cedar sure that makes sense yeah cedar
keys uh so they started cutting them
down because that's what you do yes
that's what uh yeah because they uh
trees
they um
yes a policy that does long long-term
good great yes really it's the best
thing to just cut them down well i would
offer better to burn them down because
then you're actually getting worse uh
chemical you're getting worse worse air
out of them as opposed to something that
you can breathe i think sure helpful
so that lumber's a big export
in 1860
they built a railroad because they got
the port there so they built a railroad
down that's so the road goes across
florida then goes down across bridges to
the arc okay and then it to the port so
right now you got a railroad coming
through little bridges to connect to the
yep sweet
building building building um during the
civil war
since it was a big partner that's so
civil
you know what in retrospect not the most
civil thing i'm going to call you axel
rose well did he say that yeah i did
that's tough to hear aaron cut that out
dave cut that out thanks everybody
he said what's so civil about war anyway
bam
you've been rose
and then he took off his kilt and gained
50 pounds and he became albino
so um all right so you got the railroad
and then the civil war comes and
the union takes control of it because
it's an important port sure so it's like
an occupation right
um
there's there's like like a pencil mill
that gets built there
and that's employing a lot of people
very big deal
um eventually they cut down so many so
many cedar trees that they started
closing sawmills
you see how that would work ah yeah
eventually you run out of the job
um but the city is still an important
point in uh important port until
1886 when tampa bay opens a port wow and
then it's like well that's it it's just
[ __ ] because you don't have to take
the train off of the islands it's just
right there right okay so all of a
sudden now they just overnight just
[ __ ] yep
yep
tampa bay yeah keep your eye on the
economy starts plummeting
the elites of cedar key start bailing
and moving you know to the mainland yeah
this time yeah time to go gray is
another area it becomes a really tough
town okay right it's like what atlantic
city right it's like a terrible
only around 2000 people are living there
now
there's one road in and out so it's like
an isolated place
but a lot of people don't care but you
know it's like uh oh we don't care about
that place anymore there's something
like that now still isn't there well
half of america no no but i mean like
there specifically like i feel like i've
been in florida before and there's i'm
not sure if it's tampa bay but there is
a spot where it's like there's literally
one bridge it's probably there i mean
yeah and it's literally you get on it
and you're like no
like if you made the wrong turn you're
like oh my god like i was in the car
once we made the wrong turn it was like
an hour 20 minute miss like we were like
oh my god what have you done
well that's that's probably a few play i
mean i know if you go down to the keys
that's there's a one there's one road
yeah i believe in and out
um
so
things are not great okay
and uh
now the the cottrell family
has lived in cedar keys since 1854. okay
and uh the his father william's father
had previously served a term in
um and been the president of the alabama
senate okay and then he moved here he
was the president of the alabama senate
yeah that's a thing yeah you're a senate
president yeah okay interesting i'm
learning so much about this great name
yeah i'm teaching you every day yeah was
ben franklin one of the presidents of
the senate i got to go i got to go too
and then he moved to florida he was
elected to the florida senate in 1816
1865 so
um he became the
collector of customs and cedar keys
which is an important position it's like
you know you can make a little scratch
right
he had five kids one who was william
who was known as billy okay
and the new york tribune
would later report billy as a boy got
into an argument with a 70 year old man
after the old man said he was wrong
about something
well i mean while it's probably not like
the best thing for a child to do it's
still like you're like bro you're 70 in
the 1800s like i could put my fist
through you
oh hold on oh no
quote this was an insult which the boy
could not brook and he determined to
carry his point by vigorously applying
his boots to his opponent's shins oh my
god so he's a little kid he just starts
kicking him when he says you know you're
wrong about it chop him down
he doesn't take any [ __ ] no but i mean
that is like i mean honestly like you're
small you're tiny yeah so there's
disadvantages there's advantages the
advantage is you're right i mean you
could just [ __ ] wail it's gonna be
harder for him i don't know how he stood
up i mean he's an old man he's gotta be
falling at some point and then you yell
timber yeah you gotta heal timber and
then he falls and you hear the sound of
the skull on this yeah
so the old man then grabbed billy and
spanked it
so billy goes home crying
and he wants to get even oh no i'm going
to spank him
jimmy reported he told his uncle and
another relative and they all went back
oh can you imagine being on board like
i kicked him in the his hands a bunch
and then he
and then i shoved him and then he
spanked me and they're like yeah
so i think we should kill him yeah yeah
yes sir oh thank god yes sir some people
say that i should have an authority at
home
tells me when i am out of line so that i
have a moral yeah
you're a good five-year-old yeah
five years old i think it's time to kill
him yeah
by the way validating this behavior is
gonna do long-term damage to me but
let's do it i don't think so you're at
the start of a dollop why would that be
well i mean you know the truth is that
if i just think about it like long term
like in the moment it's gonna really
help but i don't know it's sort of you
set the mental precedent for something
like this it could really really come
back to bite you later but you're right
this will probably just be a short
episode yeah it'll be fine yeah just be
quick
so
the two older men grab the old guy oh
god and they hold him while billy quote
pummeled the old man until he was
thoroughly exhausted jesus a fight you
held a guy i don't know five
you got to be pretty young because the
guy
spanked him right so he's got to be
around but my dad spanked me in my 30s
come on yeah but you paid him yes of
course i do
then he stabbed the old man nine times
with a pocket knife come on why do you
do that why do you do that that's not
cool
i'm like a fisher toying with
god damn so he's still and what and if
you're the dad and uncle are you like
boy boy
breaks breaks or are you like oh yeah i
don't know like there's no all that
paper said seven times says to me that
you're letting it happen oh yeah it says
that you've never you're not jumping in
no once you're past like two i think two
says two if it's two then it's like all
right maybe they stay
hey
yeah that's enough
hold one more
okay that's it
yeah and then the paper is like and then
he he had the respect of the town but so
no one did anything to him so it it it
was like this happened and then
everything here's backwards yeah that
gains some respect from the people like
you stabbed an old man seven times
i don't i don't know you're the new
president of the senate
i don't get it you know papers back then
they would just they would just fill in
the
the exciting stuff and then not and they
would sort of trail off and go also
lemons are good
[Laughter]
uh so i couldn't find any any really
information about his education but i i
did find that his brothers went to
private schools so he must have gone to
private schools okay
um
in his 20s his early 20s
his sister gets married okay and billy
goes fishing with his new brother-in-law
okay
oh boy and they had a bottle of whiskey
how old is he he's in his early twenties
billy is yeah okay i think okay and they
have a bottle of whiskey okay and so
they start drinking they still really
start hitting the bottle sure
uh the san francisco call quote by the
way if you are telling me that there's a
quote in a paper about this bottle of
whiskey this is leading me to believe
there's an incident today no honestly
can you speak up and then a couple guys
had a drink and then
a fish let's see this article okay
call quote uh it was a big bottle and
enough and held enough whiskey to
intoxicate a ship's company
so that's
that's a lot a ship's worth of it's how
you get ship-faced yeah completely
ship-faced yep
soon they're both wasted okay
and now they had brought along a young
boy by the way two people in this
situation is a ship's worth so this part
i don't really understand but you know
the family it does have money so it's
got to be a nice boat because they they
brought a young black guy to wait on
them okay
always on the boat fishing boat which is
what you do on a fishing trip it's
always nice to hear his family before
the civil war did own slaves so who the
you know
sure um so billy wanted
billy wants the black guy to join in on
the drinking okay interesting he hands
him the bottle okay and the
brother-in-law is like i'm not going to
drink from the same bottle as a black
guy right because then you'll be i think
you turn black i don't know what the
fear is the fears yes obviously
imagine yeah yeah i mean what what what
couldn't happen yes i mean you're white
so
yeah
billy was apparently not into that sort
of racism and he pulled his gun
fascinating and shot and killed his
brother-in-law okay so listen no no i'll
talk now okay go ahead so um i am
i'm it's a shame that that it's okay so
it's
great
great to hear yeah that he is uh
in this time he's able to think for
himself and say that he finds that to be
abhorrent yeah
it's
not
really great that he kills the guy his
sister's going to marry over he's
married to is so he kills her sister's
husband yeah yeah out on a out on a boat
drunk
um you know like i would just love to
see a uh
you know a medium volume version of that
reaction something a five not a ten he
goes he goes ten though sure absolutely
he does and by the way if you're the
black dude on the ship who's sharing the
bottle you're like hey so
um listen i am not sure about this
partying anymore i've had a hell of a
time have some whiskey i would i should
you're gonna have i would love to have
some more i would absolutely oh god
that's good oh my god you know what i
just realized yeah i have to go oh yeah
how how i'll swim i mean i don't even
care are you saying how am i gonna go or
why am i gonna go yeah sure i have
somewhere to go
uh i am in the middle of building a roof
and i have to finish it tonight
so damn it i just thought about this too
it sucked he had to die because of it
but um have some more whiskey yeah sure
i mean that's uh yeah absolutely oh my
god so good wow
yeah hopefully don't catch white
uh but uh
anywhos will be i need that was pretty
racist what you just said yeah no no no
no no call is call back no no it's call
back nice call back call back call me
[Laughter]
so
he kills his brother-in-law um he's
arrested for murder uh what grounds
goes to trial is acquitted it's just
it's really it's amazing that how many
murders they were like yeah not guilty
yeah it's all right i mean did you
murder him yeah yeah not guilty
[Laughter]
so a lot of what billy did happen when
he was drunk it was definitely a pattern
sure um sometime after he killed his
brother-in-law by the way great little
sentence there that's been normalized
a little while after kill his
brother-in-law he he cursed out his
sister because she was now poor
didn't you find a nice guy and marry him
you idiot how come you ain't got no
money well you killed my husband here oh
my god
good girl they're not get a job well
it's a lot harder
also i'm going through a lot it's really
depressing the man i love got killed why
because you shot him on a boat well yeah
well what he was in front of the bullet
number one no because you pointed the
gun at him and you shot him yeah well i
was shooting at racism yes but that he
didn't need to kill him you could have
taught him i was killing why not yes but
why don't you tell him to not be racist
teach him how to not be racist i was
trying to shoot the racism out of him
you shot him dead he died in the boat
yeah but that's because he's weak yeah
was
yeah anyway you should get a job
yeah
a relative later said of billy quote
when people talk about him when he's
intoxicated he's a normal person he
behaves sorry other way around a
relative later said of billy quote
when people talk about him when he's not
intoxicated he's a normal person he
behaves he gets along
and then you throw some whisk in him and
he turns into billy the kid
so we all
wait
hold on
that's not
is that who we're talking about no this
isn't okay i was like wait
like is this the origins
um
yeah i think like uh i mean we all have
the friend who is the billy yeah you
know i've bullied a couple times no i've
never shot anyone no way yet but uh no
it won't happen but i mean there's
they're definitely like
you know i mean i've had friends where
i'm like oh this person is no longer a
human anymore yeah yeah yeah
so billy worked for a little while uh
rafting timber
sure you know what that is
i'm still just thinking like the fact
that he like murdered this guy and like
feel like like how is he going about his
date it's like he's getting a job and
the guy's like he murdered a guy i
murdered a guy but yeah i'm really
excited to do uh yeah i like to work
here i'm excited to be a part of this
team
um
what is it called
rafting timber so i mean i'm guessing it
is a way to like get timber to other
places
by you know letting it float down a
river yeah like he's guiding it or
something yeah he did cut down the trees
and then he ties him together as a raft
and takes him down and sells them
but then he was unemployed for a long
time he must have lived off relatives
and friends
why didn't he get a job
get a job
people in cedar keys are
scared shitless of billy right he and
you're basic and you're saying this is
like a lowly area and even in the lowly
area so it's sort of like he's the joker
in gotham yeah right okay
he would take what he wanted and without
asking any they'd you know okay yeah
sure billy um one day he was racing the
family schooner near tampa bay that's
that's still said
you don't get that a lot that's still
happening the schooner was named nanny
probably after their nanny yeah who he
killed he killed
so the boat a bodhi's racing pulls ahead
of him
so he went below deck grabbed a gun and
started shooting at the boat in first
place see now again i just i'm going
back to when he stabbed an old man seven
times and i'm just this behavior
at that time it was a very that was a
learning very key moment yes really
really set the path forward with
behavioral for sure yeah okay
the crew is finally able to restrain him
now billy really loved shooting is he
drunk when he's doing this
yeah it seems like whenever he does
stuff like this she's drunk okay
from the new york tribune quote he at
times becomes crazy and will rush down
the street pistol in hand shooting at
random
mm-hmm
so this was a time when people found
that to be uh abnormal
yeah i mean back then it was like whoa
buddy yeah
yeah so while his father was alive he
protected him i think his dad died and
his dad protected billy yeah okay but
then his dad died he
he would contact the governor district
attorney and tell him billy was
untouchable
right okay he's
good
and he's not to learn do you understand
me
at one point you wrote a special bill
that put a time limit on billy's
indictment so
like
if he's future indicted
yeah there was a whole like billy only
it sounds like there's like a billy only
bill that went through that was just so
there's billy law you can't you can't
get into the billy list yeah right okay
normal yes for sure that's all
uh so it said billy would drink with
anyone but also quote he will shoot at
anybody so there you go i mean right off
the bat like
don't be the person not a guy to drink
with no yeah he doesn't sound like a guy
you drink with ever no
it was said he killed three or four
people jesus christ once an englishman
was visiting
cedar key he was in the local bar and he
started [ __ ] talking like
english people do about
americans excuse me the sf call quote as
is customary with the britain abroad he
was making disparaging disparaging
remarks about the country you know you
marry you bloody americans you've got no
idea what you're doing i mean that's
right i'll have another pandavail please
look at you your silly little hat you're
sitting some boobs aren't you dude oh
dude dude even the word dude dude jesus
call me a gentleman yeah
he's an [ __ ] you've got listen let's
be honest you moved out of home and
you've not done well for yourselves oh
we're doing fine you're not
you're pathetic look at all your teeth
they're good we have good teeth it's
disgusting that they're
nice that there's so many you're like
sharks
jesus christ you
you're really awful people like you're
really arrogant and you're the whole
thing is just falling apart like you
used to be an empire now you're not
we're still in it
absolutely you're nothing like an empire
are you gosh you americans you just get
off on the fact that you think you've
gotten away haven't you meanwhile we're
thriving we don't need you anymore we're
seeing other yes thriving how
we're doing quite well at minimum
minimum things are good they're not they
are fine
no they've been worse
no well that cannot be true
is that true
it's the worst yeah what about the
plague
it's fine the plague is not fine a lot
of us die yeah yeah but the the weak
ones look anyway you're a stupid [ __ ]
nah i'll have another ipa no no no pint
of lager no no both
so as the guy was talking [ __ ]
billy came into the doorway oh and look
at this one
he listened for a bit and then he took
out his gun and told the brit he would
quote make him tow a chalk mark out of
town sorry toe chock market so actually
physically hustle out chalk my entire
journey yeah as you go you chuck it i'd
rather not do that that's what we're
doing i'll leave
end with the child you bloody americans
in your guts we have things yes
uh and that's what he did he chased him
out of town
people were amazed that billy did not
shoot the british guy that's cool when
you set a bar solo
people like billy we're proud of you for
not killing that guy
so what to do if you're billy right
anything you want run for mayor oh
perfect absolutely totally that's what i
was gonna say be in charge uh three of
his brothers worked on the campaign
and they said what was the slogan [ __ ]
you vote for him or he'll kill you go
[ __ ] yourself yeah [ __ ] you billy
they said they would find anyone who
talks [ __ ] about billy and murder them
so it's genetic it's i guess it's
genetic it's probably that they've seen
his behavior rewarded so they're like oh
yeah this is i mean again you are
setting
you're setting like a
a precedent where you are like you can
do this and why would you not and and by
the way if he be i mean he's gonna be
he's probably gonna become mayor and
he'll be very powerful because you can
get away with everything so of course
they think
yeah and
yeah whatever all right okay so in 1889
william billy
cottrell was elected
unanimously
mayor everyone voted for him everyone
voted so he had like a putin kim jong-un
election every
single he's 32
normally one does not win every vote no
but only 101 people voted in the
election the only person who has ever
actually done that is donald trump
[Laughter]
also billy had uh uh
said he would shoot anyone who ran
against him so he was running unopposed
yeah sure okay so he got a that makes a
little more sense
and then he won okay won the election
and then he just vanished for two months
good good
good
perfect good manner
so then he comes back and he immediately
makes his buddies uh i assume i assume
his drinking buddies deputies great good
and and they become like his personal
goon squad in the town
town marshall jr mitchell was one of his
guys but apparently just going
along because he was scared of being
killed or his family being killed great
so he was like bad guy but didn't want
to be a bad guy right
so the goons
his boys would just get shit-faced
and
they would actually force people to
dance by threatening to shoot them oh so
that was a thing yeah they would go they
would go to people's houses and make
everyone come out and then make them
dance or they'd shoot it
what a weird sort of hostage situation
[Laughter]
just
what i mean it just shows you how boring
everything once again was yeah you're
like
we need to watch dancing i'm bored so
let's get the williams out here and make
them cut a jig guys they're here i feel
like
all right let's go let's yeah we're
coming let's just keep it tight this
time we'll just do
cross step cross that box fist fist bump
spin rotate backward forward then we do
the clap then run under tunnel back mom
me dad go daughters move right hey uh
just so you know i
i heard that i've seen that one i want
something different something special
here's what we'll do like a river dance
situation i don't know what the hell
that is i can't walk on water so what
we'll do is we'll do foot kick clap kick
high kick low snap snap snap snap jazz
head jazzy jazz hand move spin spin hold
sheila hold make a bridge run under go
kiss yum
yeah okay
i'm not okay great thank you that works
for me great your good boys are okay
with that yeah that sounds pretty good
we'd also like to see a pasta dough
blaze
okay
yeah i don't know what that is well it's
not crazy but it's just basically a
maybe an intimate lambada
yeah you spent too much time in mexico
during the war something like that maybe
yeah like a tango like to see maybe a
waltz some kind
yes
now we're talking you know something
like
how about a human pyramid
hello how about a human centipede
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna okay hear me you guys
go get me some thread
i'm gonna take this family and tie them
ass
ass to mouth
guys when they do that jazz hands jess
and chad says box that box that move
so one day he was really drunk in billy
yeah okay in the local barber shop sure
right of course that's where yeah yeah
that's where you do yep the drunk thing
yep
the local station agent was there with
his cousin who was a young pretty lady
okay oh boy that's a good setup thanks
uh she's engaged his lawyer in
jacksonville sure and um billy's into
her you think she's hot right and well i
mean and she's probably into him i mean
he's a wasted guy getting a haircut
pretty cool look bad boy yeah bad boys
bad boys you know the song sure
uh and
billy says quote so uh the the station
agent's name is is dopher sure
dover introduce me to that cousin of
yours and i'll marry her within two
weeks
and dopher
is like this isn't the place she's
actually engaged billy yeah so this
isn't not the place she's engaged also
you're plowed yeah you know you
shouldn't be really talking about ladies
right here
so bailey pulled out his gun
yeah and delphi pulled his gun okay and
then they started shooting at each other
jesus christ and neither of them hit
each other they just completely messed
with everybody okay dopher should feel
bad though because billy's wasted
yeah it's really i mean they're in a
barber shop it can't be that big like
you really are bad
right a lot of glass gets hit
blue water all over that floor still
a few days later billy and the cousin
are hanging out oh my god after that i
can't get him out of my hand he likes me
so much he tried to shoot my cousin
a couple weeks
lawyer from jacksonville's make me wait
six months
is it hot in here
so
they're hanging out
soon she sends her engagement ring back
to her fiance
and then the fiance hops the train and
comes to town
and he begs for her to come back and
she's like nope and she marries billy
within two weeks like he said wow like
he said
they had and then they went honeymoon in
jacksonville sure at your house
you [ __ ] douche
you're gonna watch me [ __ ] your
ex-fiance i'd really rather not honestly
it's called honeymooning oh my god
honey you look at him while you come oh
my god hey look her in the eyes really
rather it's a hurry
i wish you guys a great marriage but
honest to god enough you ever do this oh
sweet god no
it's pretty good what you mean ejaculate
yep yeah i've done that
really yes of course i thought i [ __ ]
invented that is that a thing that you
did
uh
i'm did i invent that
did you invent orgasmic did i invent
orgasming i mean look i'm willing to did
i
invent
the orgasm orgasms
i
yeah billy
nobody's
ever
done that before
i like you
you can stick around and watch this
[ __ ] man i'm trying to leave as the
hole you're not
what an inventor
what a trailblazer yeah
it's kind of a reverse hot wife left i'd
rather move
i'll move
yeah i'll leave town yeah great
well great just watch it come
good to see you
awkward ending i think
so uh
he he
billy promises her he would
change
right uh he's not gonna be an upstanding
citizen he's
not going to for sure
marry someone and then yeah yeah then
ask for change no we're drinking he's on
the up and up sure i feel like he'll
stop drinking uh so four days after they
came back from the honeymoon billy is
just shit-faced right sure
and um they're staying in in cedar key
at bellatina's hotel okay and he demands
more booze
and bellatoon is like i gotta cut you
off man
it's
it it's you're too drunk
so billy then goes after him and chases
him all over the hotel like kicking
through doors of rooms and
quote he broke through two rooms
successively but bellatina's wife threw
herself before the door of the room in
which her husband was hiding and said
that catrell would have to kill her
before he gained entrance that's not a
good that
yeah yes
well that seemed to calm him down a
little bit okay and he put his gun in
his pocket okay and then he walked out
okay
still he was upset oh dear and the next
day he had a bellatina arrested okay um
what
for just whatever right are and they're
back in they're back where he lives now
where he's the man yeah he's back in the
city he's got the power right
billy then took over the bar and he and
his friends drank until all the booze
that'll teach him to say no to a wasted
person mayor yeah
another time there was a social meeting
taking place and someone had the courage
to oppose emotion billy had put before
the group oh boy the new york tribune
quote coachella acted like a napoleon he
drew his revolver and the meeting
adjourned in a hurry
are do other people have guns
is he the only did he like is he the
first person to ever have a gun yeah
it's it's one i mean it's just that
level of intimidation it sounds like um
the the
um the man who had no name is that what
it is the clint eastwood movie it sounds
like like everyone's just too scared
right and even
like even if you had a gun you'd be like
oh god he's going to kill me if i try
like everyone's just and also he's not
alone right he has his crew yeah so
it's like if you shoot him do the other
guys come after you yeah
it's not great okay
um he really held grudges
billy yeah interesting and he had
grudges against tons of people
crazy
but
a lot of the grudges were confusing and
nobody really understood them well most
blackout grudges are not going to have
like a logical threat yes
like people are gonna be like are you
sure that guy didn't see him i didn't
like the way he looked at me and i never
will like it's like that level where
you're like okay he looked at you oh my
god and it sounds like he would
the people he had grudges against didn't
know why right and he very very
frustrating yeah because he would he
would just have like i think he'd get
drunk and have the feelings of that guy
did something i know it i just don't
remember it he tried to kill a railroad
employee one time but no one tried to
kill a railroad he tried to kill a
rabbit that would actually track he
murdered a train i killed the train
i didn't like the way it poofed at me
no one knew why he tried to kill the
railroad and play one time he stabbed a
guy for an insult and no one remembered
it happening right he was all in his
right mind made it up right even even
billy couldn't explain what the insult
was well he's like i know he didn't it
was so traumatic i blocked it out
he pulled a gun and forced a black man
now a lot that's another reason a lot of
the people there's a lot of black people
in in town okay so they're not gonna
like right [ __ ] with them well if they
step up what's gonna happen lynching
party's gonna come so
um so he forced he pulled the gun and
forced a black guy to whip a telegraph
operator in the middle of the street to
whip him yeah whip him and billy held a
gun to his head while he did it what a
cool scene
so cool to see people come together in
that way i think there's a norman
rockwell painting that i believe there
is yeah it must be a very strange
feeling at that time to be allowed like
no sorry forced to whip a white man yeah
it's gotta be a little weird you're like
i am so conflicted right
honestly i bet you'd just be like you
don't need that gun
i got that gun away
uh he was uh
oh this is not so
he he would sometimes i think it was his
brother's store because his brother
aren't a store in town
but he would sometimes block the
the entrance and exit the store right
for sure and hold this gun there and for
hours and make the women who were inside
shop and buy stuff
yeah well i mean you know it saves you
money on advertising if you could simply
just turn a shopping day into a host
it's just a situation where you're just
like hey
don't you sure you don't want to get
this summer hat too
i think you look mighty nice upon you no
i i'm
uh yes yeah and maybe you get a bag full
of uh a bag full of them nails too i
think you'd like to buy them as well
yeah i love nails yeah and all right you
know what else you can use this one at
one of those wooden pictures yeah or
lemonade stuff of that nature okay look
at that for lemonade she got a hair
you got the nails
and then you got a picture
yeah i think maybe you buy a
man's
suit
yeah yeah
yes it's an expensive one too my brother
y'all know i got him boy you must love
this store with how much dusties you're
picking out uh-huh get a giant and
pickles to get you more jasmine pickles
okay yeah that's good yeah i got the
pickles the pickles got the head
got the nails we got the picture yeah
maybe the next thing you need is some
sort of white glove
oh get seven of them
if the last seventh will be spared no it
doesn't match up pairwise yeah no i get
those yeah
you know what maybe just take air now
damn that shelf there just by that okay
take that shelf great everything guys
you must really love it here and all
that stuff first yes
what's your favorite why is it what is
it about this story you love this i hope
i can't get out yeah that's what a lot
of people say yeah yeah i can't leave
i'm starting to sober up let me give me
a bottle of one of them
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i bought you this bottle
yeah all right well you should go check
out
okay thanks for coming thank you for
have a nice night not shooting me yeah
i'm gonna shoot you no yeah yeah i
wanted to get that picture that hat damn
gloves that thing of nails and uh a lot
of other stuff that i'll mention okay
okay
come again okay i'm here again
uh
so
he seems to
he did this uh more than once it amused
him
one time the lighthouse keeper was in
town and billy shot at him who's
bringing the ships in and told them to
keep off the streets he shot him and
told him to shot at him shot at him keep
off the street stay off the street sure
go back to your lighthouse man the
shimler hotel was full of bullet holes
because he was drunk one day and tried
to shoot someone he had a disagreement
with but he missed and just kept hitting
the hotel sure
the the entire town had bullet holes all
over because he was billy hall's let's
get drunk and just start shooting and
running around right
it could also be the city that invented
glory holes so yeah who knows he's and
again he's very nice when he's sober
well it's really not going to get i mean
that's not going to go far
and so like i said cedar keys is an
isolated place and so
he's getting he can he's threatening to
kill anybody who snitches like he's it's
just that that's what you'd see in a
dumb movie like this right
but still over time in cedar keys a
grand jury issued 18 indictments against
him
but none of them were served right
because who would want to serve him
right with the yes and he's a mayor yeah
a law enforcement official would
later say
any of the 18 had could have led to
billy being executed so they were all
like major crimes
but again he came from a connection
jamie didn't have the lineup i'm italian
what are you mad about i'm italian it's
what we do
which was the most amazing like here i
am kissing al sharpton i'm italian
[Music]
oh i groped them but i'm italian that's
what we are
uh
so yeah but he also again he came from
an important family
his brother would become a state senator
so you know
the power and terrifying combination yes
that's it's hard to believe living under
that would be possible so now him being
mayor is causing even worse financial
situation for the town so the drunk
mayor who shoots everyone is not good at
the mayor job it turns out that's wild
except for some reason it's not turning
it into a tourist haven
[Music]
he he terrorized businessmen who came in
to revitalize the era so some guy come
in and be like i want to open up a story
oh you got notes about my town you know
i think it's perfect i was just going to
open up it's a perfect city name one
problem with it
name one problem with it no it's good
perfect isn't it
yeah so why is he coming down here to
build no i don't wanna you're trying to
take the beauty of this city and move it
to another town
he's trying
and i am the mayor i just came i will
kill you i'm in charge and i'm the mayor
bang ow yeah i killed that guy all right
everybody let's get some stakehoms
to his own brother's mercantile business
closed due to lack of customers so he's
driving out well why not i mean he has
the system you just hold
go get some of that product
come on
no one wanted to go to the town no one
wanted to go through town it was just
and why do you think that is dave i
don't know
um uh so tons of stores are closing
while he's mayor tons of businesses
their assets and they fold sure
business business owners are just
they're just scared to stay in the town
because they can't make a profit right
so
but billy still has the support of a
group of people because they are
benefiting in some way right so it's the
the bad people who are
dave i know it's weird to think of walk
me through
[Laughter]
so
i mean they'd say he was decent when
he's sober but no he's okay when he's a
sober guy
i'm like you know what i'm done with
this sober [ __ ] i mean he's not okay
he's a nice guy when he's sick i don't
give a [ __ ] he's never sober we just
played a pickup game with him he's never
sober he's great he shot my dad
but then he came to the funeral he shot
me at the mural yeah but at the funeral
then after he sobered up he's like i'm
sorry i shot you and that was your dad
that was nice he gave you flowers
well he stole them and he shot someone
who had flowers at the funeral but after
that that's my cousin yeah i know it was
your cousin but after that he was like
you want to go on a boat ride yeah i
don't know which i later found out was a
plot to kill me look yeah but that's
because he got drunk but
when he invited you i know
very sincere he's a real he's a nice guy
dr jekyll mr drunk he is a little bit
okay
but
good at heart
shooting hearts uh that's better
so
uh
he's like teen wolf but with alcohol
yeah and so people say well he's gonna
be sober he's also from a great family
you know it's all the [ __ ] excuses
that are
always bandied about
he's reelected of course and a landslide
well he got 67 votes out of 124 so he
didn't run against wow
67 out of 124 yeah so he barely squeaked
by isn't that literally half but i think
that
there must have been more than one one
running because he he
oh it's not and that's not half but it's
close okay interesting okay uh but you
know it's more it's more than it's but
it's clearly like he won unanimously
and then now
it's way less unanimous yes right so
yeah so it also probably wasn't a clean
election anyway well
yeah if you can imagine that
um and that's because the votes weren't
secret they made
how do you know before
what is why did you not write my name
by the way i just want to make it clear
to everyone here
i want this town to be great i have a
great vision for it the citizens of this
town will thrive and if you write
another name i will be killing you okay
legally i will get away with it i'm
gonna leave okay that's your option but
as long as you ain't writing another
name
i'm voting for shooty mayor that to me
so
so there there were people scared
shitless because and they did vote
against him um at this point
a woman who lives in the town miss roose
bell
steps up oh my god now she she at this
point knows no one in florida is going
to help
so she writes to the president of the
united states wow
and she explains how billy's drunk and
he's always threatening to kill people
who's the president uh harrison okay and
yes harrison okay yep and uh she writes
up all a bunch of the awful stuff that
billy's done and says none of the
christian men in the town
are stepping up they're too cowardly to
do anything right
and she's like i have no husband or sons
that he can kill so i'm gonna reveal
what he's doing okay
so president harrison reads the letter
okay
and he names
someone to go down there to be the new
customs collector for cedar keys okay
j.h pinkerton oh my god
wow okay
so his worlds are colliding
his job
is
oversight of revenue and maritime law so
he's like a legal illegal authority in
the town right it's a port town he's got
some legal he has authority over the
ports yeah so he's got authority over
this part right
it's a job a lot of guys want it's a
very influential men want this are you
freaked out if like the president is
appointing someone to be you probably
are like something happens it's not
great if the president himself is like
this guy's coming i'm going to shoot at
the white house from here now billy also
thought he should have gotten the job
right of course of course the mayor maps
of course i also wanted to do that
as a matter of fact i should be the
mayor president
[Laughter]
mayor president king mayor president
king boom
secretary of everything
uh a problem started immediately with
billy oh boy
billy was the customs inspector but that
position is below the customs collector
wow
so pinkerton authority is new yeah uh
pigerton lands a job because of his
connections in the republican party okay
so
he's not really concerned about the
mayor
of cedar keys like this guy can't really
touch me okay
and uh by the way he can shoot you
yes
uh very soon after arriving billy tells
um
uh pinkerton to resign
yeah you should probably you have a hell
of a run
you should it should probably be done
and and then he tells billy he's like we
actually you're gonna resign that's not
possible
it's illegal for me to do that
so instead of doing that
billy comes to the customs house on may
9th
and he was with
marshall mitchell
again and
well that's the guy that is the marshal
but
we think he's the marshal he's we think
he's working with billy because billy's
threatening to kill his family okay
and so billy wants to fight pinkerton
okay but pinkerton pinkerton's like
pinkerton he's like he's in the customs
house he's like it's after 5 p.m so i'm
not gonna open it up i don't fight after
five billy
we're closed captioning not available
billy gives up he's like i'm gonna leave
because he they're not gonna kick in the
door because pinkerton would kill them
right
so
he gives up but he said quote watch out
pinkerton i better not see you on these
streets or i'm gonna kill you he's like
i work here what are you talking about
you're the mayor
so pinkerton knows that that's a
legitimate threat sure and he actually
doesn't go out on the streets okay
i've molded some tunnels
now the mayor gets pissed because
pinkerton won't come out of his house
what's his problem what's he scared of
is the question why is he not coming out
he's very easy to come out
it's almost like he's built his life was
threatened for some odd reason
so
he goes to the house and he
he tries to force a guy to go in
go in and drag pinkerton out on the
street so he could shoot him but the
guy's like i'm not gonna die
and grab him by his coat no and drag him
out of that i'll kill him you didn't do
anything but i don't wanna i don't have
anything to do with this go in there and
kill get his coat on his head
and then bring him out to the street and
i'm going to shoot him like a dog yeah i
might get killed
i don't want to do that i'm in charge
i'm scared of everything so i don't want
to be i know but i can't i'm not what do
you want name is
as long as there's nothing that disrupts
the fact that you'll drag him out of the
house by the way i know picked a smart
guy when i told you to get him because
it will kill him that's very smart
you have a good mind and okay and an
even better heart
and that's why i've always appreciated
years you
have we met
no i've always found you to be
incredible
thank you
you told me to go get some sandwiches so
i'm gonna go hurry get a bunch of them
and get enough for five of us okay
that's a great great guy bye
where am i
so
the guy the guy's like i'm not dragging
him out i'm not and then billy's like
okay and he beats the [ __ ] out of the
guy all right you have it your way
here we go i'll just beat you merciless
you asked for this
now an agent of the florida central road
is pinkerton literally just he's not
leaving at all he's not going to leave
his house he's like come in and get me
i'll kill you i love that yeah that is
it is it's a great response to just be
like all right honey there's no more
leaving
so an agent of the florida central
railroad came through but he was stopped
by billy
who who had a double barrel shotgun okay
and the agent somehow managed uh to
disarm him and get out of town so
somehow he got away he probably like
threw a whiskey bottle he was like save
it yeah um billy next threatened to
horse whip the episcopal minister and
his wife
a respected couple the fact that we have
different whips it's like
no no that's not for a man that's for
horses okay so he threatened a horse
whip the episcopal minister and his wife
who are very respected at the town i'm
going to whip you
and your lady and your dumb wife you
like that huh
where's your god now senator god
so the minister flees jesus he goes to
tallahassee he complains to the governor
and then he comes back to cedar keys and
his parish
has to escort him to his house so all of
his [ __ ] church right like
back to his house right
so pinkerton goes to jacksonville and he
comes back with four u.s marshals to
capture billy this is good this is this
is how you know your run as a mayor is
going pretty well yeah oh yeah um so
they arrest
marshall mitchell but they cannot find
cottrell because he went into hiding
when the marshals came okay
so then pinkerton set a sent to telegram
to washington explaining things or not
going great okay
quote
he then called me all the files names he
could think of and allowed an angry
voice and said i will make it a hell for
you and you're set as long as you stay
in cedar keys
and many other vile things equally bad
using all the time the most profane
oaths and vile epithets
is
he didn't say that but pinkerton said
that oh okay okay
so he's like you know he's explaining
what happened at the customs house and
he's like this it's not good [ __ ]
right
so he asked he's asking for the federal
government to get involved pickerton
he's like you got to get some boys down
here
so a ship
the mclean
good lord was sent on may 15
1890.
so
this is one of the rare times where we
have invaded
america america
that's right okay
so several reporters from new york were
invited to go along on the expedition oh
my god
billy's now known across the country
newspapers are reporting on his actions
yeah like there's a murderous mayor
um
one wrote quote the prominent promptness
with which he will level a pistol
whether without provocation on unarmed
men and defenseless women
has won for him the reputation of being
a determined and dangerous customer well
but by the way this is why you don't let
a seven-year-old stab an old man
mean we flagged it immediately
it's just terror it's just it's again i
mean it's like you know if
here's what i'll relate it to okay when
you have a kitten
and you want to play with the kitten
and so you're like oh the kitten likes
it when i like play with its belly and
then it like scratches me and it's like
we're having a game well then you're
creating then you're creating a
situation where
when your kitten is a cat
it'll always be like oh i can claw the
[ __ ] out of this person yeah so what
started is like hey it's all good it's
like now you've set a terrible attitude
forever it's the same thing if you let
puppies bite yes
and they're always like i'm gonna play
by biting you i like the idea that i
went with kitten and you went with puppy
i think it's good that's who we are i
think
anyone listening is probably really
impressed with this run
it's good it's real yep very real
perfect
so on the mclean captain thomas smith
and his crew
come and they are not welcomed by
everyone in the town sure
so the town but by everyone in the town
not everyone in the town
the front so no they're an abusive city
relationship you don't know the mayor
like we do we love him he's a great gift
giver please
he's just a little drunk
you've got to see him sober he's the
nicest man y'all don't know him like we
do
he's fantastic
so
union troops have taken the town 25
years before and there's still residual
anger oh wow so it's the yankees coming
in again this is this is why
the new york times quote the people here
have lived so long in an unreconstructed
condition that the appearance of the
united states semen in the streets
intent on forcing order and obedience is
especially gallic
that is actually i mean
i can think of so many things that that
is applicable to today yeah yeah yeah
the day before the ship arrived the new
york times reported marshall mitchell
mitchell had been released and the and
quote few good citizens of cedar keys
are outraged okay
so
they go into the town
these soldiers and
and and
they started we need a battalion of
therapists
they start searching for billy okay and
they're going door-to-door and kicking
indoors wow like they're doing exactly
what the people feared right that would
happen yeah right they're like oh the
that was a long time ago now we're gonna
take over your town
[Laughter]
they're going into homes without search
warrants they're tossing the houses
they're hitting people with rifle butts
etc they're doing this [ __ ]
it's a classic united states occupation
a local threatened to shoot captain
smith or anyone who tried to enter his
house and then he told the crowd that
had gathered
gathered that the ship was there on
behalf of the us government and everyone
was like yeah they all agreed with him
like this is not okay not okay yeah give
us billy or give us death billy replied
that anyone raised sorry captain smith
replied that anyone raising a hand
against his men would suffer i have a
question ow
i didn't literally mean i meant punch
but i said raise your hand so that's
hong kong can we talk about what
happened
i did say it so the boys are gonna shoot
you if you well you don't you don't have
i'm dead yeah you don't
i just died that's right so i'm sorry i
keep talking to you i'm a ghost yeah i
like ghosts
what's happening right now
yeah it's going to be confusing for a
while
it turns out when you're good i'm a
ghost pal yeah you're a ghost buddy uh
you talk to ghost men yeah that's what i
yeah
who are you talking to sir i see ghosts
okay recent ghosts all right after about
20 minutes i don't see him anymore
well i'm gonna head to heaven
okay see you later yeah thanks for
coming by do you need anything
i could really go for a pastrami
sandwich
it's really not worth me coming
i think it is i'll see what it's like
okay i'll judge it when i get it thank
you i hear it's really good up there
oh is that the sound of you going up i'm
going up
it's interesting i didn't yeah okay you
can stop going up can i get a pastrami
oh sure okay so i gotta take it back
down if that's okay so if you go down
you go to hell
well i promised him well you can't break
a promise or you go to hell
i don't even know what kind of bread he
wants
do it on rye okay all right well what a
nightmare
hey so i got you this pastrami sandwich
but no i wanted that on white well now
i'm going to hell
well you should because you didn't have
to break your real prick you
bad ghosts oh my god bad ghosts
so
people
you know
they're obviously very
upset by this yeah they're upset by what
i mean they're upset people occupational
yeah it's now unoccupied they're you
know going door-to-door and [ __ ] yeah
well it's called spreading freedom and
this is and they they're mad at the guys
that would go to houses and make
everyone come out and shoot and dance
like this you know i mean they're
protected well that's not us that's us
doing that to us but the truth is it's
like that's what is so alarming about
politics and always is is how they are
able to the lesser of two evil i mean
it's just constantly this like race to
the bottom and you're like this one's
better i'm in love with it yeah that's
right fight for more
neither of these work for us
so
the times
and democrats said the soldiers were
called quote
hirelings dogs scamps and many other bad
names sure scamp is really effective
scamp's rough how dare they captain
smith told them he wasn't going to
listen to any more threats and we'll put
a stop to it and pretty much everyone
was like okay okay because again that's
what they're that's what they do yeah
yeah still captain smith was horrified
by what he saw in cedar key uh quote the
newspaper reports are not only not
exaggerated but do not tell one half of
this man cottrell's crimes the fact is
that people here are in a perfect state
of terror and are unable to obtain
assistance or protection from state
authorities owing to the influence
wielded by catrell and the methods
resorted to in frightening and
terrorizing witnesses florida's just
making a whole lot more sense now
[Laughter]
at the same time as as they were
searching the town captain smith sent
three different groups into the woods
and swamps to try and find cattrell and
he's doing a swamp check yeah i believe
him to be living with the gate
five days of rations they go out they
don't find billy
because he had he had escaped and headed
up the sewanee river and he was off okay
so the mayor has fled the town they
yes
they try to go after the mayor yeah
rogue mayor mayor on the run right
uh they try to go after him but there's
no way they're going to catch him in the
swamp okay and uh
there's concern if they go inland
that they would then be ambushed by
angry angry floridians right oh my god
so
still a fear
even though they knew billy had escaped
pinkerton requested that the ship stay
close by for people who are concerned
that billy's going to return okay so we
got to have some emergency hatch yeah
like let's just have the ship there so
people won't get freaked out they know
that a change has come right so the ship
is docked okay and
they have a big like cannon type gun
uh-huh
and they keep shooting it and they keep
who keeps shooting it the soldiers okay
and
and they're sh and they're shooting
small arms
but they say it's for practice but it's
clearly to
scare or intimidate right so they're
just like by the way
but these are people are already like
terrorized so it's not really a calming
right
what seems like everybody is like
the way to get them to believe is to
scare the [ __ ] out of them and then
they're like they're too scared so we
need to go in there and scare the [ __ ]
out of them so they never get scared
really double scared it's better
so the city council holds a meeting
where one of billy's brothers announced
billy would never return to cedar key
and that the
city council should declare the office
vacant okay
as far as
forces illegally searching houses
congress starts getting all these
letters about it and they're starting to
get worried and then president harrison
said look it's a local issue but because
local law enforcement couldn't handle it
he had to bring in forces to deal with
it and that's that's what it was so you
gotta deal with it right billy made his
way to alabama because he had family
there right
he was arrested on july 19th
but then released on a 2500 hundred
dollar bond wow
and then he never showed up to that
trial
okay
on november 5th it was reported he
ha
he was in montgomery alabama for several
days quote
drinking freely and acting in his usual
style sure i mean honestly i didn't need
to know that what she does it's his
thing yeah i'm back baby
that's right oh god i'm still the mayor
you're not i'm here no word of beer
of fear you're the mayor of beer i'm a
mayor of beer
okay
that's sad
and the best
but this is
uncomfortable number one
why you're crying you realize you're
crying yes
i thought it's been crying
okay
my father let me stab a man
okay probably
should have been a better puppet
you're making me feel weird
i didn't know what to do
so i stamped it okay
and then it said it's gonna be done
and then i was getting a haircut
and then i was in charge
i'm gonna have to kill you no yeah i
just said you know too much no you're
the devil no he's a devil i'm not i have
to kill you it's me frank [ __ ] you frank
i'm your cousin you killed me first you
son of a [ __ ] why'd you let me stab
that old man frank
just stop instead of a [ __ ]
i have a ale
sure
uh give him two yep
so
he was arrested after getting drunk and
starting a fight with a restaurant owner
sure
and
the charge is disorderly i already know
what that situation was he was asked to
not drink anymore yeah oh for sure
charges disorderly conduct and after he
left
the police
station after he got out on bail or
whatever sure billy swore he would get
revenge on the police chief okay
uh
why the police chief because the police
chief arrested him for sorry and then
let him go after okay well he didn't let
him know a bail but yeah he was you know
yeah you're gonna take that well i mean
he ran away the last time why not just
run away yeah you're gonna take it
though i mean it's some guy right
there's not gonna take it yeah that's
some [ __ ] that's right what was the
last time it was against the law to
punch a guy it's always been against a
lot of people that's right it's not
illegal anywhere okay it's a good talk
so
he he says he's gonna get revenge on the
police chief and he tells friends he's
gonna kill him and the chiefs the chief
the police chief's friends are like hey
you got to watch out for this guy
legitimately so crazy to be like i just
want you 20 of my closest individual
friends who have just kind of met in
this new situation to know i'm going to
kill the police chief but it's always
worked yeah i guess yeah right i guess
yeah public intimidation the next
morning he sends a dual challenge to the
chief who ignores it two challenges oh i
see jade's like let's duel in the stream
she's like okay i'm not going to do it
in the street so you didn't rsvp would
you like to or not i said no okay
damn it he's good
chief just ignored it he's like i'm not
rsvping so billy rolls up to the police
station in a horse-drawn carriage at
11am perfect
police chief isn't really interested in
whatever billy's planning on doing right
and as catrell gets out of the carriage
the chief of police shot him twice with
a shotgun holy [ __ ] bailey was hit once
in the torso and once in the uh eye the
face wow he died bleeding in the street
jesus christ yeah
that's not how you duel hey you're not
in florida anymore it's not how you duel
no but he was like i got it seems like
he was really building up for an event
too a horse-drawn carriage yeah he was
ready to have a duel in there and once i
get up there i'll pound on the door set
off the fireworks okay that's when we'll
do the whole thing yeah yeah and that's
when i'll go up there and i'll
jesus christ my eyeball's gone my head
i'm dying i'm dead does anyone want
anything from heaven
oh i would like a pastrami sandwich what
bread
i'll see what options i have okay
so
the montgomery advertiser called it a
quote bloody and ghastly spectacle jesus
christ i bet the
chief of police pleads self-defense and
the coroner agreed
you can tell by the shots through the
body that this and the eye that this was
uh
retaliatory that's right because billy's
a monster and yeah he was clear he'd
threaten to kill him so you know yeah
uh new york new york times it's just it
it felt i was assuming at some point he
would be killed but it just was starting
to feel like everyone was like he can't
kill him
he's like nah he's got skin he's got
organs he's our special guy no no his
brain's all over the ground no he's
special no look his brain's everywhere
he was nothing big it's yeah no i think
that if we shoot him the world will
regular brain
dead just don't do it can i have a
whiskey yeah shoot him jesus christ he's
still moving
the new york times uh
headline was quote catrell killed the
last
the san francisco call headline quote a
bad career ended so everyone's just like
[ __ ] this guy yeah
it is believed that in his life he
killed somewhere between five and ten
people that's crazy thank you mr mayor
for your service see just a complete and
total tyrant and right lunatic um
sources san francisco calls springville
journal
uh iron county registered new york times
tacoma daily ledger new york tribune
times and democrat ridiculous history
podcast smithsonian magazine
history of florida past and present
historical and biographical by harry
gardner cutler
i love a harry gardner um i uh
it feels like we're getting closer to
that than further away from that
right like if you had told me that
10 years ago
i'd have been like
that's really wild and now it's like
i could see that literally happening in
florida
well you know what's funny there was it
wouldn't surprise me if there was a city
that just did that like just was like we
are no longer
we've we've seceded i was trying to do a
dollop on this like three or four years
ago
i think it was before trump but um oh
are you gonna talk about this dude who
has no no it was a texas and it was a
female sheriff
and she was like terrorizing all the
liberals in the town like she was like
and yeah it was like this crazy story
and it was like how do we stop this yeah
they were powerless
no but i mean when you think about like
how
our country
is now
states do have great
fantastic yeah
thank god we made it great again yeah
um
but like states obviously have a lot of
power the governor has a ton of power
and the federal government
you know can't really do too much about
what is happening with the governors
so
it wouldn't surprise me like in some
version of it if
you know we get to the point where
i mean because states talk well there
was
recently that weren't they talking about
like oreg like certain counties in
oregon were talking about leaving oregon
oregon and going to idaho like they were
just like we want to be part of idaho
like so that sort of [ __ ] i mean i just
feel like we're getting closer and
closer to
on what axel rose would call an uncivil
war
well there's also the california
counties that have always wanted i think
it was all right he's like why don't we
just split off from this place that
makes all the money right well by the
way i was never surprised that trump was
super popular in a county called orange
um i don't understand i don't either but
uh but yeah i mean i i don't know i like
the way it is now i mean it is just
constantly shocking i mean you know
before coveted it was like man this
country is [ __ ] and then like covered
and now it's like oh my god i can't
fathom it like it's like we're talking
about like it feels like we're always
scraping in the bottom of the barrel and
the second that you've scraped like
there's another barrel under the barrel
and you're like oh my god the barrel's
just it's endless barrels endless
endless barrels of monkeys yeah and we
just are like constantly finding new
lows and oh yeah you know
i mean i yeah i don't want to turn it
into climate change but oh my god what
is there something wrong i don't like
what they're saying what do you mean
they're saying it's really bad i haven't
seen it but then you see like you know
like i mean the biden tweet yesterday
where he was like we're ready to do it
it was like dude we're not we're not at
the don't tell me you're at this lie to
me lie to me tell me you're not about to
start tell me you're like deep into it
you know
um
but i mean all the complications that
are going to be brought about because of
that it's just this
nightmarish storm of everything i think
it's gonna be great i don't know
i don't know what could go wrong every i
just look like here's the thing we're in
good hands our government is good that's
the good news and there's competency on
every level righteous yeah and
smart well once the democrats get the
senate and the house yeah they could
actually do some [ __ ] yeah once they get
the senate in the house they can they
can actually do something yeah they just
need to get this it's just about getting
that you get control get control they
need to get like 83
well once you have every senator yeah
that's what i want to do i want to see
how i wouldn't i want to
finding the way
who to blame it on
you know like the damn senate
parliamentary or whoever it's going to
be just inventing new you know
boogeyman or whatever yeah
but uh but yeah no okay good great great
fantastic super good feel good wonderful
happy about everything yeah
great um good so we
are
happy
these are hot dogs oh oh did uh did
dylan give you that shirt dylan gave us
those shirts didn't he he told us where
to get him oh that's right dylan reeves
tickled
living a wonderful life in
new zealand yeah well we'll see how long
that uh i'll marry you
[Laughter]
all right everybody god bless gobble
gobble
you